знаки в жизни как их замечать Если вы не
научитесь замечать знаки То вы упустите
огромное количество подсказок которые
помогли бы вам принимать более
правильные решения Всевышний или
Вселенная всё время посылает вам знаки
относительно того как нам поступать в
той или иной ситуации Проблема в том что
мы не знаем что такое знаки и
соответственно мы не замечаем их
досмотрите это видео до конца и я
расскажу вам что такое знаки и как их
замечать Ну а пока подпишитесь на мой
канал поставьте колокольчик и поехали
Что такое
знаки знаки - это необъяснимые события
явления совпадения или символы которые
воспринимаются нами как подсказки или
указатели на нашем жизненном пути они
дают нам намёк или предупреждение о
чём-то важном знаки могут быть как
проявлением наших внутренних таких
интуитивных что ли ощущений так и
проявлением внешних
обстоятельств указывающих на решение
подход или даже на требуемые изменения
знаки часто дают нам ответы на вопросы
которые нас волнуют либо подтверждают то
что мы движемся в правильную сторону Ну
или неправильную замечать знаки - это
процесс наблюдения и внимательного
анализа сигналов и намёков которые могут
повлиять на наше поведения решения и
направления в жизни Они часто
проявляются через
обстоятельства интуитивные ощущения
события или даже через встречающихся
людей их восприятие требует осознанности
и умения замечать детали которые обычно
ускользают от нашего внимания это способ
общения с миром своего рода интуитивный
компас который может нас направлять нас
к более осмысленно существованию если
конечно уметь прислушиваться к ним
кстати пока мы записывали эти видео для
YouTube канала один из членов моей
команды рассказал реальную когда его
знакомая спешила попасть на самолёт у
него не получалось нестыковки машина
подвела пробки и так далее В результате
она опоздала на самолёт который К
сожалению разбился ужасная трагическая
трагичная история но это
показывает на то как важно обращать
внимание на знаки
давайте рассмотрим Какие бывают знаки
первая группа знаков - это частые
совпадения
ситуации когда Вдруг вы сталкиваетесь с
подозрительно частым совпадением
например вы что-то придумали или
размышляете над каким-то решением
Приходите такие в офис А ваш коллега Или
это может быть даже Случайный знакомый
говорит Ты знаешь я сегодня подумал и
решил что нам наверное лучше это сделать
вот так-то и так-то и это в точности
совпадает с тем что вы придумали или с
тем решением о которой вы размышляли а
ещ знаете Бывает
такое такие нифига себе Ну особо сильно
не обратили внимание на это далее идёте
по своим делам и вдруг читаете на
билборде или в газете фразу говорящую
вам о том же или вы замечаете одно и
тоже число в различных ситуациях
например время на часах номер на машине
страницу книги Бывает такое так вот это
Явный
знак
второе обращайте внимание на
синхронности Иногда вы начинаете
говорить человека которого давно не
видели и в тот же день Он Вам пишет или
звонит или кто-то из ваших знакомых
выражает ту же мысль или идею что и Вы
недавно будто вы думаете об одном и том
же в одно и то же время если совпадение
это когда происходит совпадение мыслей
действий или решений то синхронность -
это когда это происходит у нескольких
человек или в нескольких местах в одно и
то же время очень часто синхронность и
совпадения Идут вместе Рука об руку
расскажу вам историю моей
ученицы Однажды она захотела поехать со
мной в путешествие но у неё на тот
момент не было достаточной суммы денег
Она говорит ну она рассказывает мне
говорит в то утро я увидела вашу рекламу
и хотела купить ваш тур но я знала
говорит что у меня не хватает денег на
карточке И вот я говорит открываю
банковское приложение и с удивлением
вдруг обнаружил у себя что на счету
именно та сумма которая точно совпадает
с ценой за ваш тур а оказывается именно
в тот день ей турагентство вернуло ту
сумму которую она когда-то заплатила за
билеты и отели которые полгода назад она
отменила То есть она собиралась поехать
куда-то в путешествие потом это отменила
и она говорит я полгода била с этим
турагентством чтобы они мне вернули эти
деньги и надо же именно в то утро те
деньги упали го мне на карточку и эта
сумма в точности со стоимостью вашего
тура в этом примере вы видите сразу же и
совпадение и синхронность третий вид
знаков - это повторяющиеся ситуации и
события очень часто когда мы не замечаем
или игнорируем какие-то знаки они
повторяются и повторяются вновь пока мы
их не заметим когда какая-то ситуация
или тема начинает повторяться в вашей
жизни это может быть знаком того что вам
нужно извлечь из этого урок или обратить
на это внимание знаки такого рода очень
часто указывают на нные вопросы или
скрытые возможности например
вы вдруг начинаете встречать людей с
одинаковыми интересами или проблемами с
которыми сталкиваетесь вы сами или
бывает что вы сказали кому-то что-то но
сами это не делаете и такая ситуация
повторяется и повторяется пока вы не
поймёте что вы сами не выполняете то что
говорите делать другим или другая
ситуация например вы потеряли какую-то
вещь Потом нашли Её потом потеряли ещё
раз
потом снова нашли потом потеряли ещ раз
скорее всего это знак того что эта вещь
вам не нужна или что надо обратить
внимание на то что внутри этой вещи вот
такая ситуация у меня была с моей женой
она купила портмоне знаете которая на
магните приклеивается к смартфону она
один раз потеряла потом второй раз
потеряла потом третий раз потеряла Ну
каждый раз она находила так вот это было
предупреждение что не надо ценные вещи
носить в НМ
потом попросил её выбросить это портмоне
пока она не потеряла его вместе со
своими карточками и удостоверением
личности она туда положила своий
карточки удостоверение личности заметьте
три раза теряла три раза теряла и три
раза находила я понял Это знак сама
ситуация нам подсказывает избавьтесь от
этого парме иначе вы потеряете ценные
вещи Четвёртый вид знаков это
Невероятное везение бывает что знаки
проявляются в виде невероятного везения
вот вроде только подумали об этом а уже
возможности для этого открылись или
появились перед вами Если у вас так было
обязательно Ставьте лайк этому видео вам
нужны были ресурсы для чего-то как раз
сразу же они откуда-то появились вы
подумали о нужном человека как такой
человек встречается вам на вашем пути вы
подумывает поменять работу Как
неожиданно встречаете старого знакомого
который работает в этой сфере или может
предоставить
чека это кажется не просто совпадением А
как будто мир направляет вас к вашей
цели вы знаете Однажды я консультировал
одного своего ученика он с Москвы
специально прилетел ко мне на
консультацию Он хотел запустить новый
бизнес это достаточно крупный бизнесмен
но не знал где ему найти хорошие
возможности при этом он Заметь не хотел
заниматься стартапом то есть запускать
бизнес бизнес
нуть гото Бине
РУП банков которые занимаются
реализацией имущества компаний которые
не справились с возвратом Долгов или
специальные фонды стрессовых активов при
крупных банках вы знаете при каждом
крупном банке есть фонд стрессовых
активов куда они сбрасывают свои активы
или должников которые не смогли погасить
долги А те потом уже продают с дисконтом
с пониженной ценой так вот Я ему сказал
что самый лучший вариант конечно это
взять на работу человека который работал
в этой сфере потому что он точно знает
все ходы и выходы и знает какой актив по
какой привлекательной цене можно сегодня
купить у банков так вот он улетел
вечером и сразу же по прилёту
возбуждённом оказывается когда он летел
он всю дорогу спал я говорит когда
проснулся на подлёте Ну проснулся я
говорит уже на подлёте к Москве когда я
проснулся
и его сосед ему говорит Ну что выспался
Ну я такой да и у нас го завязался
разговор с ним и Выяснилось что он
бывший руководитель подразделения одного
из крупнейших российских банков по
работе со стрессовыми активами и самое
интересное он месяц назад уволился из
банка И в данный момент находится в
поисках работы сразу же после самолёта
они поехали обсуждать условия совместной
работы Вот как это работает у вас тоже
были периоды невероятных везений
Напишите в комментариях обязательно мне
будет интересно это почитать У меня
лично таких случаев было море пятый вид
знаков это нужная информация в нужный
момент вы знаете бывает вы размышляете о
каком-то сложном решении и вдруг случа
случайно слышите краем уха Разговор в
кафе где-нибудь где обсуждает схожую
тему или вы видите статью в новостях с
полезными рекомендациями это знаете
ощущается как ответ на ваш внутренний
вопрос У меня однажды была такая
ситуация когда ответ на мой сложный
вопрос Я случайно услышал Во фразе
официанта когда они разговаривали между
собой Там два официанта стояли болтали
между собой и я просто услышал как один
официант дал ответ на мой вопрос Хотя
они говорили между собой либо Бывает
такое что вы можете услышать ответ на
свой вопрос в совершенно неподходящей
ситуации от совершенно неподходящего
случайного человека вообще не связанного
с вашей ситуацией это могут быть фразы
из фильма Пока
или вопрос даже который вам задали вы
знаете вам вопрос задали вы такие
Опаньки Это же про меня или даже
ситуация которая в точности похожа на
вашу но произошла с другим человеком
если вы хотите больше узнать об
эффективной жизни я создал пространство
Где собраны все мои знания инструменты и
лайфхаки Там собраны активные люди
которые занимаются саморазвитием И если
вы хотите развиваться со мной то
подписывайтесь на этот мой Telegram
канал шестой вид знаков это внешние
символы и образы Бывает такое что у вас
в жизни трудная ситуация Ну каждый
человек в этой жизни конечно же проходил
через какие-то трудные ситуации Вы
наверняка меня понимаете или вы стоите
перед сложным выбором и знаки к вам
приходят в виде символов или в виде
образов например вы замечаете необычный
мо именно необычный Мост который
символизирует И соот вам
с каким-то человеком с которым у вас
проблемы Либо вы внезапно увидели сову
Ну не обязательно на природе в жизни Ну
где в кино в телевизоре или открыли
книгу и там это может быть знаком к
проявлению мудрости и терпения или вы
сидите в парке и на вас плавно
опустилось Пёрышко это может быть
символом того что надо
вос цитаты говорящие о терпении или силе
Духа что может восприниматься
как то что вам нужно проявить терпение и
стойкость очень часто такие знаки
приходят к нам как ответы на наши
внутренние вопросы или сомнения
вообще Вселенная устроена Так что когда
вы во вселенную транслируется свой
запрос обязательно вам приходят ответы и
ответы могут приходить в виде символов и
образов седьмой вид знаков - это
необычные препятствия и барьеры знаете
иногда знаки приходят нам как необычные
препятствия и барьеры они мешают или
препятствуют нам в осуществлении наших
целей например когда была пандемия
ковида я хотел сделать прививки Ну все
делали прививки Я думаю мне тоже надо
делать прививки а то как-то неправильно
я пошл в ближайшую
поликлинику мне там
сказали прививку нужно ставить в той
Поли
Ну это было необычно потому что обычно
прививку ставили в любой первой
попавшийся поликлиники Ну хорошо Я через
пару дней пошёл в свою поликлинику по
месту прописки но там почему-то сидел
терапевт и измерял температуру пульс
давление слушал лёгкие для того чтобы
дать допуск на
прививку это тоже кстати было очень
необычно Я подошёл к нему Он всё у меня
замерил и сказал знаете Мне не нравится
как работают ваши лёгкие у вас похоже
небольшая простуда поэтому сначала
пролечить а потом придёте и он отказал
мне сделать возможность в том чтобы
сделать прививку хорошо это была вторая
уже добросовестная Моя попытка поставить
прививку Ну потом я по делам уехал в
командировку в Украину и вот в Киеве мне
ребята предложили поставить американскую
прививку файзер Я обрадовался такой
возможности коне Ну и врач назна мне
дату и время
за день вечером накануне завтра мне идти
к нему навстречу ставить прививку прямо
за день до этого вечером врача который
назначил мне приём взяли за нелегальную
продажу вакцин от ковида то есть там
антикоррупционная служба
его ну просто закрыли арестовали таким
образом я сделал три добросовестные
попытки поставить прививки Но все они по
тем или иным причинам провалились причём
все причины были необычные
Я понял что Шеф но в моём случае шеф -
это Всевышний мне не даёт добро на
прививке Я не стал делать их мы
рассмотрели основные виды знаков если их
перечислять их может быть очень много
Главное чтобы вы поняли основную идею
что знаки что какие бывают знаки и что
такое знаки обязательно Напишите в
комментариях все знаки которые вы
замечали в своей жизни обязательно
Поделитесь с другими людьми этими
знаками читая ваши знаки многие люди
поймут какие ещё бывают знаки в этой
жизни и на что стоит обращать внимание
Давайте теперь перейдём к вопросу А как
замечать знаки первый конечно это надо
развивать осознанность и
внимание знаки - это про осознанность
Чем выше ваша осознанность тем больше у
вас возможности общаться с этим миром
посредством знаков общение через знаки -
это просто ещё один канал общения с этим
миром чем внимательнее вы относитесь к
окружающему миру тем проще становится за
замечать все необычные и значимые детали
проводите для этого каждый день немного
времени в тишине вы знаете вот эта суета
беготня она на самом деле мало того что
расфокусировать наше внимание Оно ещё
как раз-таки забирает у нас возможность
видеть эти знаки поэтому проводите
определённое время каждый день в тишине
Наблюдая за своими мыслями и
ощущениями это поможет вам научиться
распознавать когда что-то чувствуется
Особенно если это выходит за рамки
привычного
Ну например прогуливаясь на природе или
даже по
улице приучите себя обращать внимание на
мельчайшие детали какие люди попадаются
какие ситуации привлекают Ваше внимание
чем больше осознанности в вашем
наблюдении тем больше знаков вы сможете
замечать постарайтесь обращать внимание
на Всё необычное что выделяется из
привычного ряда второе Работайте с
интуицией и внутренним
ощущением иногда знаки проявляются как
внутренние ощущения или мысли то есть не
внешние а внутренние которые возникает
вдруг внезапно интуиция Может подсказать
вам что какое-то решение или ситуация
имеет большое значение для вас учитесь
доверять вашим внутренним сигналам и не
игнорируйте те ощущения которые вызывают
у вас интерес или беспокойство Например
если вдруг у вас появляется сильное
желание что-то сделать или куда-то
поехать без явной на то причины
отнеситесь к этому внима
это ведь необычно возможно этот порыв
связан с каким-то важным знаком или
возможностью третий способ анализируйте
повторяющиеся события или темы Обратите
внимание на ситуации или людей которые
встречаются вам снова и снова знаки
очень часто проявляются через повторение
особенно если определённые темы
или проблемы становятся постоянными
Постарайтесь понять какой урок или Какая
информация может стоять за эти
повторами Например если вы часто
встречаете информацию о конкретной книге
событии или
человеке Подумайте почему это происходит
Возможно это знак что вам стоит глубже
изучить эту тему или связаться с этим
человеком четвёртый способ Используйте
знаки как руководство для рефлексии и
анализа иногда знак Это просто повод
остановиться и переосмыслить своё
поведение отношения или подход к жизни
когда заметите что-то необычное Задайте
себе вопрос что это событие хочет мне
сказать такой подход помогает
использовать знаки для внутреннего роста
и решения текущих вопросов Например если
вы сталкиваетесь с трудностями или
неудачами в одном и том же деле это
может быть знаком того что вам стоит
изменить стратегию или подход
пересмотреть цели или развить новые
навыки пятый способ
научитесь видеть необычное в
повседневном иногда очень часто Я даже
скажу не только иногда знаки прячутся в
обыденных вещах это может быть Случайный
разговор Неожиданное совпадение или даже
фраза из фильма которая вам запомнилась
важно уметь находить значимость в самых
простых проявлениях жизни так как именно
в них часто заключены важные подсказки
например вы идёте по улице думая о
каком-то решении и вдруг вы замечаете
рекламу или вывеску с надписью которая
отвечает на ваш вопрос такие совпадения
могут быть знаками указывающими вам
нужное направление шестой способ
доверяйте своему ощущению синхронности
знаки часто проявляются через так
называемую
синхронность когда события не связанные
напрямую вдруг складываются вместе и
создают важный смысл то есть каждое
событие По отдельности не даёт смысла а
вместе то вы вдруг начинаете видеть в
этом смысл чем внимательнее вы
относитесь к таким моментам тем сильнее
развиваются ваши способности к их
восприятию и использованию в жизни
например вы думаете об идее для бизнеса
и буквально через пару часов встречаете
человека который может помочь её
реализовать эти совпадения если
воспринимать их осознанно могут стать
мощным источником вдохновения и
руководства Давайте подведём итог
чтобы замечать знаки нужна развитая
наблюдательность и Доверие к своей
интуиции способность видеть необычное в
повседневных событиях знаки можно
воспринимать как обратную связь от этого
мира показывающую вам верное направление
или намекаю на необходимую корректировку
чем больше вы будете доверять этим
сигналам и замечать их тем чаще вы
будете получать подсказки помогающие в
достижении ваших целей и укреплений
уверенности на своём пути А ещё больше
подсказок инсайтов и стратегий о том как
улучшить свою жизнь и вывести свою свой
бизнес на следующий уровень Вы можете
получить в моём Telegram канале
подписчики моего телеграма всегда идут
на шаг впереди и получают все мои знания
первыми я уверен что вы будете среди них
ссылку я оставлю в описании к этому
видео внизу